fun kiss is all it takes Dua Lipa
without her rumored new man Trevor Noah
yep check them out Wednesday night in
New York an eyewitness tells E.T the two
seemed very into each other having an
intimate dinner date and sharing a good
night kiss do you gotta have moves like
Dua Lipa you know less than 24 hours
later Trevor broke the news he's leaving
The Daily Show
um my time is up
I uh
et's Lawrence Comedy Central has been
working with the host for a long time to
figure out how Trevor could maintain the
demanding schedule and the deal he
signed in 2017 was only for five years
no departure date but Trevor's World
Tour is booked for 12 nights next fall
in his native South Africa when I got
back out there again
I realize there's another part of my
life that I want to I want to carry on
exploring well could it could it be
about the money too The Daily Show is
one of late night's lowest rated but
Trevor's one of TV's highest paid host
time Jimmy Fallon at reported 16 million
dollars per season this will be my last
year the exit comes five months after
James Corden announced he's dropping out
next spring Trevor was seen as his
possible replacement Why did no one tell
me about this oh James because it's a
surprise
[Music]